it's a boss level though this this movie
you did with with Mel Gibson with Naomi
Watts yeah Frank Grillo
yeah that's Will Sasso I've heard
there's the williston I've heard natsu
I'm not from you I've heard from people
who are like dude this is gonna be the
this movie is I guess they're freaking
out about it are the studio's off
[ __ ] tonight look and I look like I
look like something's wrong I look like
I have bells Paul no you look a great
picture handsome guys and let me get a
look at that [ __ ] come on you look like
the young guy like digest happy be here
yeah it's not a good help Mel's a trip
he's malleus let me tell you something
one of the most misunderstood
[ __ ] and a talented guy oh my
oh my that we're still gonna kind of
that this guy's still dealing with this
[ __ ]
after going sober apologize you like
doing his thing all he did hey sugar
tits thing it's like oh you're still
it's like let me tell you something
we're done if this unless the society
has completely abandon any measure
forgiven well they have that he's still
working though yes I love them all right
you know listen thank you that made him
take a seat for 10 years yeah that's
what happy said that yeah said listen I
knew I was gonna I knew I was gonna get
blacked out for 10 I knew I was going
hey dude you got 10 years they say with
the sugar did they say it was an
anti-semitic rant I mean you know it was
and there was also the other thing about
the black there was they I've been heard
there was this I there was a couple of
unfortunate incidents he gets very drunk
but but but you know what masses all the
guy and by the way you notice it's like
there's a great it's like there's a
great story my brother's reading this
thing at Che Guevara I think it tells a
story about like che was a kid and
Argentina and he's driving through the
countryside he was from means his dad
was it was before he became a
sociopathic murderer his dad was a
doctor and lever had a car and Argentine
at that time nobody had a car and he
catches sight of Che make it fun of like
the bike that like the peasants work in
the fields he pulls a car oh he grabs
him he plant some other Road sizes don't
you ever think you're better than
anybody talent is the only aristocracy
and I [ __ ] love that and Mel is room
absolutely a hardened parcel that
statement hit talent
he's a fantastic director Apocalypto
dude they attach on the cries yeah
has he done in rave heart Braveheart
that's our ridge come on dude oh by the
way oh he's this Ruiz dad he's a race
he's a race he'd been Apocalypto they
spoken I mean they spoke an ancient like
get out of your mouth [ __ ] hey I adore
him you know I heard this story about
yeah yeah he said he have a problem with
alcohol and he would go a little crazy I
guess he throw weapon lethal weapon oh
yeah he'll tell you stories about him
he'll tell you stories about her steam
her stories like the old days a
Hollywood like Christie's in a room bite
him and his other handsome Australian
friend and then Andy Warhol just peek
around a curtain take a picture and then
disappear back behind a curtain and then
over here there's Warhol again like
anything I mean it's the best
he tells the best story yeah it is Mel
all good in the in the head is he best
yeah he's also notice Mel's a hyper
hyper bright guy he's you're seen do
there's a moment on the since by the way
he dislocated Frank's during the fight
he dislocated Gorillaz jaw dis looked
knocked it out of place they do reach in
Frank's mother literally like like pop
his job back again he's the kind of guy
who like I've only had a bullet in there
where the signs yeah
he's the kind of guy who does this tell
correct McClung right everything he does
is that contentious [ __ ] like he'll he's
eating I'm were talking and because I
was right next to him I basically was
there for three hours and he wouldn't
even taste he's eating putting butter on
his bread knees goes and he takes his
thing's gonna and then he goes smell I
want cuz he can't drink let me smell
that because I swear to god he's got the
forum's he's literally like you need a
Rosa yet she's gorgeous
beautiful and she's a writer that he's
directing her next movie yeah baby
fantastic writer yeah yeah but but but
it's like but you look at a guy like Mel
and you go that guy's that guy's a
monarch that guy's that guy's one of
those dudes like Frank and I look
through each other a couple of times the
lake it's it's it's it's it's Mad Max I
mean it's it's it's Martin rig some
lethal weapon
that's rigs its raise pigs so yeah man
he he is he is one of my favorite people
and and and by the way you get a call
like I got from Mel Gibson I'm awesome
and you never forget it man and then
Stallone calls you saying Mel said hey
Jose sly bells talking about you might
want to talk to you about I mean it just
is [ __ ] great it's such a great
marker ah come on we're just like with
Mike these are my childhood come out I
don't know tonight is a big screening
tonight the Grove they're screening the
movie and I'm not going anywhere near it
cuz I just don't want to be into it yeah
this little dude you know you do do I
use like you know I don't I don't want
to read anything I don't seen your
reviews I don't wanna see I just want to
see numbers I want to see bar I don't
give a shakes you you want to die down
the rabbit hole you know though you know
some idiot in Wichita doesn't like I'm
gonna do my job you it's just like the
screenings for the studio heads screens
for all the studios so CAA is putting it
on you and these guys are murderous you
know rampaging Marauders either SAS I
love it so you couldn't and and it's and
it's listen it is a it is a absolute
people towards a game change its against
Frank Grillo's career in life ain't
gonna be the same after this movie he
does something extraordinary in that
film he's in Italy right now shooting
with Ryan Reynolds
yeah he's the bad guy in hit man's
bodyguard - so he but he Frank did some
in there scenes
cuz I he he'll admit this but he got a
squeeze out he didn't want a trio his
son of the movie and he called casting
and said you can't put me I know Joe
wants REO in the movie we can't he's
never acted before Bubba that kid steals
every scene he's in with his dad Wow and
you know it's amazing you think about
you think about your child right you
look at that kid in a way that I don't
care the best child actor in the world
correct you're never gonna look at that
kid the way you do your own flesh of
blood so those scenes with them it's
like our DP said that movies funny as
[ __ ] until it's not and then it's even
better